[Aplausos]
[Música]
bolivia y chile son como el pimpinela de
latinoamérica sí es cierto que comparten
fronteras pero por todo lo demás no
podían tener más diferencias entre ellos
bolivia es uno de los países más pobres
de todo el continente mientras que chile
es uno de los más ricos
bolivia es uno de los abanderados del
llamado socialismo indígena mientras que
chile está considerado como el motor del
neoliberalismo absoluto y por si fuera
poco estos dos países llevan años con
eternas disputas territoriales sin
embargo aquí una cosa que estos dos
países tienen en común sí amigos de
visual política estamos hablando del oro
blanco
esto es lado
no ese oro blanco me estoy refiriendo al
litio el metal que se encuentra en las
baterías de vuestros teléfonos móviles
vuestros ordenadores portátiles y esos
coches eléctricos que probablemente en
muy poco tiempo inundarán las ciudades y
carreteras de todo el mundo lo llaman el
nuevo petróleo el metal más ligero de la
tabla periódica su valor se ha
multiplicado por 10 en las últimas dos
décadas y su demanda no para de crecer
entre el 60 y el 80 por ciento de las
reservas conocidas están en lo que ya se
conoce como el triángulo del litio
de una zona que comprende parte de
argentina bolivia y chile en estos
países el litio no solo es abundante
sino que además está muy cerca de la
superficie y es muy fácil de extraer
dicho de otra forma esta zona puede
convertirse rápidamente en una especie
de nueva arabia saudita del oro blanco
la forma en la que se encuentran se
encuentra en desiertos de sal lo que se
conoce como salario y eso es muy
distinto que sacara el litio de rocas
duras es mucho más barato y más
eficiente de estos tres países bolivia
es el más afortunado el llamado salar de
uyuni tendría entre dos y tres veces más
recursos de litio que los yacimientos de
argentina o chile sin embargo pese a
tener los mayores yacimientos de litio
bolivia es el país que menos minerales
está produciendo así que la pregunta es
qué está ocurriendo en bolivia porque
nadie quiere explotar sus minas de litio
hoy vamos a responder a esta pregunta
pero antes vamos a ver un poco de
historia
un nuevo potosí los que lleváis tiempo
suscritos a visual política ya sabéis
que tener muchos recursos naturales no
significa que vayas a ser rico en
bolivia lo sabe muy bien
[Música]
este país tiene todos los recursos
naturales que os podáis imaginar sal
plata litio gas natural y sin embargo
bolivia es uno de los países más pobres
de latinoamérica durante siglos las
minas de plata de potosí financiaron
toda clase de gastos por parte de la
corona española durante el siglo 16 y 17
de hecho todavía en españa decimos esto
vale un potosí cuando queremos decir que
algo es muy caro
[Música]
sin embargo los nativos bolivianos
vivieron pocos beneficios de la
extracción de este metal y millones
murieron bajo condiciones de trabajo
extremas y por eso es razonable que el
presidente de bolivia evo morales tenga
tanto recelo de las empresas extranjeras
que vendrían al país a explotar el litio
además no nos engañemos el verdadero
negocio aquí no está en la explotación
de los minerales sino en todo lo que
viene después
[Música]
para que os hagáis una idea mientras
hacemos este vídeo la tonelada métrica
de litio cotiza en el mercado a unos
9000 dólares sin embargo si tomamos ese
litio en bruto y lo convertimos en
baterías para teléfonos móviles por
ejemplo tendríamos unos ingresos de
entre 1,5 y 5 millones de dólares por
supuesto que este es un cálculo muy
aproximado y que habría que tener en
cuenta otro tipo de gastos pero la
comparativa es muy ilustrativa y eso es
lo que explica estas noticias el
presidente evo morales inauguró en 2013
la primera planta de carbonato de litio
y en febrero de 2014 la primera planta
piloto de baterías de ion de litio pero
no sólo eso en bolivia el litio está
nacionalizado eso significa que si
tienes una empresa privada de minería y
quieres operar en suelo boliviano tienes
que asociarse con el gobierno y crear
una nueva compañía público-privada y
esta nueva empresa cobraría dinero por
abrir
a instalar las máquinas y explotar el
mineral etcétera etcétera etcétera pero
el litio que sacaran de la mina no les
pertenecería a ellos sino al gobierno de
bolivia que es el único que tiene
derecho a venderlo
y os preguntaréis por que bolivia
necesita estas empresas extranjeras para
extraer el recurso natural es que no
pueden hacerlo ellos mismos lo cierto es
que no la minería de hoy en día no
tienen nada que ver con el típico señor
que nos imaginamos que va con un pico y
una pala a picar piedra hoy en día se
utilizan máquinas de alta tecnología y
sobre todo ingenieros muy bien
preparados y en un país pobre como
bolivia esas cosas escasea
eso significa que desarrollar tu propio
sector tecnológico minero llevaría
décadas y por eso es tan importante
contar con empresas que ya conocen cómo
se explota el litio cómo se extrae cómo
se vende en el mercado internacional y
tienen las máquinas y el personal
cualificado y por eso incluso a evo
morales que ya sabéis que no es
precisamente un gran amigo de las
multinacionales ha tenido que salir a
buscar inversores el momento que
tengamos de avión industria de litio
bolivia va a decidir el precio del litio
para todo el mundo
hola quiero decirles estados o
empresarios privados expertos de él y
pueden sumar
[Música]
pero cuál es el problema pues que como
os decíamos antes en bolivia el litio
está nacionalizado y eso significa que
las empresas extranjeras que quieran
venir al país y sacar beneficios se
tienen que asociar con el gobierno y de
ese dinero que ganen tienen que pagar un
impuesto especial de minería que llega
hasta el 37 5% es el más alto de toda la
región por si esto fuera poco boliviano
es precisamente un entorno donde sea
fácil hacer negocios según el banco
mundial
bolivia está entre los 50 países donde
es más difícil hacer negocios al mismo
nivel que sierra leona
en otras palabras que si tuvierais que
invertir vuestro propio dinero en
minería de litio os iréis a bolivia os
buscaría es otro país pues bien eso
explica por qué aunque bolivia sea el
país con mayores yacimientos de litio
sea el que menos minerales está
explotando hasta la fecha
[Música]
fijaros bien en la gráfica porque en
este momento en el que hacemos el vídeo
australia es el líder en explotación de
oro blanco y eso es llamativo si tenemos
en cuenta que los yacimientos de este
país son cuatro veces más pequeños que
los de bolivia y además los sueldos que
cobran los australianos son seis veces
más altos que los de los bolivianos es
decir que no se trata de una cuestión de
recursos minerales o trabajo barato sino
de buenas o malas prácticas económicas
[Música]
pero esperar un momento porque este no
es el único problema no olvidéis que la
gran ambición de evo morales es que
bolivia se convierta en un líder en
fabricación de baterías de litio pero
cómo pueden conseguir eso sin empresas
extranjeras que se instalen en el país
sí ya lo sé el gobierno si quiere puede
construir una fábrica de baterías por
supuesto que puede hacerlo pero la
tecnología las patentes y el
conocimiento sobre cómo se hacen estas
baterías pertenece a empresas como
samsung panasonic o tesla y sin la
colaboración de estas compañías
bolivia tendría que invertir décadas en
i + d + y para poder llegar a competir
en el mercado internacional y ahora os
preguntaréis qué es lo que están
haciendo en chile- lo están haciendo
mejor que los bolivianos ahora lo vamos
a ver
[Música]
y sigue tras los pasos de bolivia
durante años chile ha sido conocido como
la disneylandia del libre mercado
concretamente su sector minero era uno
de los más libres que existían en el
mundo
hablamos de un país cuyo principal
sector económico es la explotación del
cobre y por eso en el año 1981 la
dictadura de pinochet sacó la llamada
ley minera que permitía que las empresas
privadas pudieran tener el 100% de la
propiedad de las minas como os podéis
imaginar esta legislación disparó la
inversión extranjera en el país de
repente llegaron montones de empresas
como la australiana bhp billinton o la
suiza xstrata
y si ya sé lo que estáis pensando que
todas estas multinacionales llegaron al
país saquearon sus recursos y lo dejaron
sumido en la pobreza verdad pues os
equivocáis todas estas empresas
canadienses suizas o australianas
llegaron a explotar el cobre sí pero
también ayudaron a financiar muchas
empresas nuevas con sede en santiago de
chile- trabajadores chilenos y
presidentes chilenos
hablamos de compañías como minera
escondida o antofagasta minerals en
realidad gracias a esta oleada de
inversiones extranjeras
chile cuenta hoy con un sector minero de
importancia internacional de hecho
muchos de esos ingenieros que faltan en
bolivia viven en los mejores barrios de
santiago de chile- y eso significa que
desde el primer momento los chilenos
contaban con una posición de ventaja
para poder liderar esta carrera por el
litio sin embargo en el año 2016 la
presidenta del país michelle bachelet
dejó muy claro que este mineral era un
caso especial
[Música]
una de las primeras definiciones que
adoptamos fue acoger el llamado de la
comisión de reafirmar el carácter
estratégico del litio propiedad de todos
los chilenos y chilenas y mantener su
condición de material no con cesc y bleu
en otras palabras que el gobierno de
chile quiere seguir los mismos pasos que
el de bolivia pero con una diferencia en
este caso el país si cuenta con la
tecnología los recursos y el capital
humano necesario como para poder
explotar sus recursos mineros de forma
eficiente
[Música]
por supuesto que muchas de esas empresas
extranjeras que estaban dispuestas a
invertir en el país han perdido el
interés pero la economía chilena ya
cuenta con sus propias compañías a eso
hay que sumarle el hecho de que hasta el
año 2014 los otros dos países que
conforman este triángulo del litio
bolivia y argentina eran mucho peores
para la inversión y como ya sabéis en el
país de los ciegos el tuerto es el rey
asi que chile jugaba con una gran
ventaja
[Música]
hasta ahora la gran sorpresa ha sido
argentina mientras chile y bolivia han
optado por nacionalizar sus yacimientos
de litio y hacer todo lo posible por
ahuyentar a las empresas extranjeras
argentinas con el gobierno de macri está
adoptando una política muy distinta y
está acaparando la atención de todos los
inversores internacionales en detrimento
de chile y bolivia pero de eso vamos a
hablar las próximas semanas si nos lo
queréis perder ya sabéis suscribiros al
canal mientras tanto ahora la pregunta
es creéis que bolivia y chile serán
capaces de aprovechar esta oportunidad
que les ofrece el litio o será argentina
quien gane la carrera
podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios mientras tanto si queréis
conocer más a fondo todos los cambios
que está realizando evo morales en
bolivia hacer clic en este vídeo
y si os han gustado este vídeo dadle a
like y nos vemos en el próximo un abrazo
y hasta pronto
[Música]